[ Laughter ]
-All right, all right.
-Oh, God.
-It's not gonna be the same
working here without you, Phil.
-I'm gonna miss you guys.
-Truly sucks
you're getting fired
just 'cause people
can't take jokes anymore.
-I guess I should've just
deleted my old podcast
the moment I got the promotion.
-It's just not fair.
So now we can't even use
the N-word
to describe people anymore?
-Guess not.
-Well, uh, we all chipped in
and, uh,
we got you something, Phil.
-Introducing the new
Fisher-Price
Podcast Set for White Guys.
Now you can shout every
crazy thought in your head
without ruining your life.
It doesn't record
anything at all.
-Wait. I probably shouldn't
podcast anymore.
I promised my bitch wife
that I'd --
-Phil, we're white guys.
We need to be able to say every
dumb thing into a microphone
and not get in trouble.
-It's just how God made us.
-The new Fisher-Price
Podcast Set for White Guys
comes with a mic, headphones,
and a soundboard
that doesn't record [bleep].
-Welcome back
to "The Mind Dojo."
I'm Phil, and we got a ton
of stuff to get into today.
-Plus, a battery life
of three hours, minimum,
so you and your
inflatable co-host
can rant about everything
you want, like sports.
I mean, when you think about it,
I'm blacker
than Colin Kaepernick.
-[ Laughs ]
That's so funny, man.
-Entertainment.
-If there was a show
called "White-ish,"
the left would lose their minds.
-[ Laughs ]
You're so right, totally.
-And science.
-Sorry, Big Pharma.
I'm not just gonna put
some crap in my body
without doing
my own research first.
Anyway, today's podcast
is sponsored by
Diamond Hog
Male Enhancement Gummies.
Look, guys, I don't know what's
in this stuff, but it works.
[ Door opens ]
-If you want to get as hard
as a diamond --
-What the hell are you doing?
-It's not what you think.
-You promised we wouldn't
podcast any more.
-This is the new Fisher-Price
Podcast Set for White Guys.
It doesn't record.
-Fisher-Price?
So it's a toy?
-Yep, and I can say
whatever I want now,
and I can never get canceled,
even the N-word.
-Why do you need to do that?
-Because if I don't, they win.
-Who's they?
-All of them!
We can't let them beat us.
-Wait.
Is that camera on?
-Yes.
-So you are recording this.
-Just for my livestream.
-That doesn't make sense.
-How else am I supposed
to get donations, Sharon?!
-New Fisher-Price
Podcast Set for White Guys.
Get yours wherever
tactical gear is sold.
-Ages 34 and up.